this is a Fox News Alert protesters
marching in cities across the country
after tonight's release of that body cam
footage of the arrest and beating of 29
year old Tyree Nichols he died three
days later five former Memphis police
officers are facing charges of
second-degree murder kidnapping and
assault let's go back down to Memphis
where Fox News senior correspondent
Steve Harrigan has been standing by
tonight sounds like so far so good Steve
Shannon about three or four hundred
protesters managed to block a section of
Interstate 55 for about three hours
police really just let them take control
of that section of Highway and chant for
a few hours that crowd has pretty much
melted away you can see the downtown
area functioning normally here there
were real concerns that that tape could
spark violence here in Memphis so far it
simply has not happened a number of
merchants boarded up their windows but
there have been no reports of violence
no reports of injuries there are also
real concerns they're releasing that
tape of violence on a Friday night could
play into protesters hands
officials were worried about school
children being disturbed if it was in
the middle of the week but so far that
bet seems to have paid off a quiet
Friday night here on the most part in
part because uh the government seems to
have acted really swiftly they're
getting praise both from the family and
from the family's attorneys saying on
the one hand they fired the police
officers they arrested them they charged
all five with murder both the family and
their attorneys basically saying this
was a good first step so far we're going
to need to see convictions but that fear
of widespread and serious violence here
has not materialized Shannon back to you
Steve thank you so glad to hear that so
far thank you very much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else